hi guys I am back playing Emily wants to
play for you because you already enjoyed
the last one and I was kind of worried
because their quality was rubbish
because you guys know but I don't have
the best equipment for this stuff so I
just kind of trying to find my way
around a bit apparently you don't care
you still find it fun probably because I
was crying in the last episode but I was
reading some of your comments and it
seems like there are ways around this
let's see if we can if we can play this
game without dying
oh okay so someone told me I didn't know
this as fast as broken look at that
where did that break that's careless as
never this is pretty loud in my ear
someone told me no I had to look at her
for him I'm not supposed to move but
anyway I was told yeah yeah yeah we know
you're squeaking yeah I was told that
apparently this yeah like a lamp next to
here that I'm not moving
thank you okay where's my first I
against an F yep okay so apparently
there's like a lamp or wait hey I got a
little supposed to have found this place
yet she's creepy I never realized that
she like waved like that before
is she just gonna I hate this yeah [ __ ]
what there are no words but it's like
[ __ ] creepy I'm guessing she's just
gonna kill me there right
Emily hello Willie I've got a housemate
called Emily and I always call her amber
Willie ah ha ha I'm so funny racket it
was so cute
totally missed all that whatever we were
scared of our own daughter she was
standing in our bedroom last night
staring at us we're going to start
locking her down in the basement
oh [ __ ] Emily in the basement
ah poor God it's a cipher a hole fell
through Emily's old room into the other
side of the basement today we know Emily
had something to do with it but we don't
understand what's going on no hole wait
whoa what a hole fell through Emily's
old room into the hall the basement
today we know Emily had something to do
with it but we don't understand what's
going on so you think that emily is like
making holes into the basement there was
a box of three very Emily talks to them
as if they can hear her how have you
done that
what she's just through the planks okay
fine whatever
this is what you can't progress because
those things everywhere I think there's
one more that we haven't seen yet cool
see you later all right um I'm I was
just about to say I've become so brave
with this game but make me mean oh it's
just like that everywhere
everyone you can look out for them
everywhere it's it's not fair
shoo bugger off oh you still I mean I
played by the rules I don't want to play
I feel I gonna have a little party that
means mean do you think I'm not supposed
to go down there yet do you think I'm
supposed to wait till it's a bit later
on maybe wait where's the TV because I
saw someone watching a TV in this game
this is the front room this is where a
TV would be right don't stay still winky
face hmm
I see what you're trying to do okay okay
let's go do this let's go down a lot I'm
a winner there's things to I'm
stair-step I actually prefer the clown
to a creepy doll thing I went in the
basement today to bring Emily some food
so bad she was like she wasn't breathing
there is no way I'm gonna finish this
thing
just let me please get to the basement
before you start doing this stupid
boxing things this game it brings out
the worst of me I don't normally talk
like this
what is Emily sound like a raging
creature of the night like wait that's a
vampire isn't it I don't know but she
sounds creepy doesn't she like super
goofy dead end
oh we found so that's that's where we
come in from the other place okay that's
cool touch creepy sound
it's okay Emily we'll find out your
secrets I feel kind of sorry for her I
feel like in a way she kind of wants to
maybe talk to us I don't know like
chaunce our help or something but her
friends oh my god are keeping us away
that was scary my flashlight went off
okay oh that's cute
okay no now what Emily's going for the
dolls keep appearing around the house I
don't know this is just me this is
really happening I forgot it hmm
good I forgot that they said that they
found Emily down there dead so there was
something weird with Emily she have a
lot of weird dolls and so her parents
locked her in the basement and she kept
on making holes appear around the house
so she could get out the basement but
then she died she died she died and now
the dolls are still here that I saw
Emily that was obviously a ghost it
seems like this is a dead end there what
am I supposed to my god what am I
supposed to do I'm just supposed to
survive the night is it like a five
nights at freddys kind of thing yeah cuz
I know the story now follow Emily me
just stay here
okay back up we go now what I don't know
what to do I swear like no as always
don't think I've ever finished her again
not not one way you can actually die I
finished those ones where it's just kind
of like scary but you always go through
anyway so you can't actually die but
typically I'm scared I play them for you
guys you know I'll try that that's what
matters the most isn't it I try I try
and then I cry and then I quit I just
don't know what to do I don't know
wanting just trying to keep myself sane
by acting insane to remind myself that
I'm actually sane because that makes
sense doesn't it there's a lot of
waiting in this game and it makes me
impatient so you know I'm just like over
that pop I can't even jump
that's my jumping noise oh okay come
over the fridge picture in the fridge so
Molly who's Chester I ever met Jesse Oh
Kiki Kiki
Keke's the girl Kiki Kiki as Kiki and I
have a mat no I thought Chester was the
clown oh my gasps to double check that
piece of paper I hope that I'm a really
terrible memory what did you say again
Chester mr. taters mr. taters
there is mr. taters talk of the devil
and he shop here a polar bears chapters
but teachers is a lot a lot less scary
soon right hey so I prefer AIA taters
tell two news project roars no sorry I'm
not gonna I'm gonna do my awful Irish
accent I can't do it all right so this
was her bedroom and this was the hole
that
how could she smash a hole through
through from the basement into her
bedroom and Lisa says wait Kiki we can
do this no I just jinxed it choice my
mum is a where is she there she's okay
what's the scary goes it's a little bit
boring but it's okay because I'll be
scared again soon I know it'll take you
by surprise so I'll just be I'll be in a
false sense of security
oh and I'll do something stupid
that's what nobody happens yeah
so we do it let's go I'm not go in that
way stop open up [ __ ] okay let's go
to the blackboard whiteboard I think it
tells me what hey hey close the door in
my face guys freaking room huh okay one
more gate one more game cuz this is the
last character isn't it this must be new
yet I just want to see what the white
boys say don't run don't run from
Chester okay oh but the white board
lights so I do need to run through
Chester oh no so this game is just gonna
be me running around
oh dear this is naked I'm not very good
at running away from things cuz I'm too
scared I panic and never like look at
that ass no don't look at my ass I'm
bored
anybody can you like anyone got a vamp
oh did it run did I make it
did I make it did I make it there we go
amazing I hate running
oh god Monica Monica Monica erotic tour
don't cut it going everyone gonna vanish
everybody much hey Emily gonna ban shiz
it's scary music don't like it okay
I founder of journaling pumps right now
amazing can i watch TV I was too eager
that's enough for now I think you have
enough jumps kids for tonight and
screaming too much there's too much I
hate jump scares well I don't do this
yeah I hope you enjoyed that please give
it a thumbs up if you did I played this
for you because you loved the last one I
was scared but you know if I was gonna
play it again but I did play it for you
guys cuz you really liked it and you
have the wonderful comments let me know
what's the time so hopefully there's not
too much more of this game so maybe I
can finish it do you think we can finish
it let me know in the comments if you
think we can finish it and if you want
to see it finished have a little bit
dare evening oh my god hey what is that
why